you have a favorite Woody Allen story I
have a pretty good one
what I think is a pretty good one which
is he he asked me what Twitter was to
explain Twitter to him you have and so I
was kind of telling him you know it's
140 characters and you kind of write
these sentences and I don't really
understand the point unless you know
like you're a musician and you're sort
of advertising a gig or you're a
comedian and you're doing one-liners or
something and he said well what you know
what's a good example of something that
someone has has put on Twitter and so I
went on it and I looked and I said oh
you know do you know Joyce Carol Oates
is and he said yeah I know her
personally yeah I was like well of
course cuz you're Woody Allen yeah um so
I was looking and I was like oh here's a
great one okay she wrote time plus or
sorry tragedy plus time equals comedy
right that's great yeah he goes that's
my line and I was like what and he goes
in crimes and misdemeanors Allinol does
yeah we said it you know we did it about
40 times I don't think she intentionally
stole my line I think maybe she just
remember you know but it's it's very
funny no I see the point I think my only
example was his own quote there's
another reason why he should probably be
on Twitter yeah he should be on Twitter
yeah it's probably got a lot of goodwill
on the vine and you just kept going
through lines and he was like you know
yeah four score and seven years ago I
that was mine too
nauseous